[Music]
General we are
discovered
good
wait nice it's a CL R
Dr I'm not built like other
men generals got GED in their
masses move along now those in power
only see me as a gr unfit for higher
office just like witches at black m but
I follow in the footsteps of Alexander
the Great and
Caesar evil minds PL destru if you look
down you'll see a
surprise once you see it you'll always
want it Sorcerer of death Construction
I must warn you I will not leave a
second of
command I will win by fire I am destined
for
greatness I found the crown of France in
the
gutter and place it at top my own
head
that's is where the body
bur you want to be great but you want
nothing without me say
it I believe I speak for all of us we
will all sleep again without This
Vermin whose country are we
in
[Music]
mine